he's Erin Donald the Rams defensive
tackle joining us got the Chargers
coming up and good to have you back on
the program Erin how are you this
morning
all right we just had a discussion on
how much is your max bench so the most
you've ever been just once it's one rep
I think we had 540 was the highest so
how much is the mode i I went 400 so
your max bench is what 500 what's the
most you've ever seen a teammate okay if
I had golf and you had to bench Jarrod
golf how many times you think you could
bench him well Sean Mannion I'm sure you
could do probably 200 times pretty
strong for my dad what a fans say to you
on the street in Los Angeles so they
always decided to you know brag about
that and did happy that I'm here and
always relations and things like that
and you know just just you know the
normal fan thing and just how excited
they are does anybody ever want to block
you so nobody wants you to tackle them
or nobody wants to say can I try to
block you cuz I would actually like to
I'd like to know what that feels like
though I'd like to know what it feels
like to get hit by you all right I'll
come out in Los Angeles
I might go to that let's see let me see
and I'll figure out my schedule and see
if I can
about to practice now you can't
blindside me though Aaron I got to see
you coming let me know where a Philip
Rivers Jersey is that no give me a
quarter back you don't like tomorrow the
new quarterback tackle rules explain
this to me like but what are you allowed
to do and not allowed to do this now
because you know they understand they're
trying to protect Claire's but you know
you tackle quarterback they say you
follow putting weight on the top of
those last with all types of stuff so
it's kind of hard to play play the game
of football now no physical you know so
it definitely tough one approaches and
when they say you taking a quarterback
down and you fall on top of womanís you
know roughing the passer so well really
much you can say is tough just don't get
it
we had von Miller on yesterday and he
said he avoids it by just going for the
strip sack what do you think of that
line yeah that works too being an
interior guy you know I really get them
blasts that's too many times so they
pretty get to see me coming and I had
embracing the way I got a sacrament most
of the time I'm taking them down and you
know sometimes I fall on top of himself
do you ever do you ever have a
conversation with a quarterback no not
at all nothing talking a little trash
just a little treasure I'm talking some
stuff too but but give me the
quarterback who talks to you well I
can't imagine that they would want to
upset you but does anybody what they try
to be nice to you really don't say trash
talk to me or not pretty much what's the
difference with this year's defense as
opposed to last year I know you've got
different personnel but do you feel the
same or different with this defense
um you know we always had great players
in his decent but we definitely added
some you know all-pro talent that you
know helped us anchor down a lot
stronger on from the run game to the
pass game so yeah it's like we've got a
special unit it's like you don't you
know any opportunities you get to have a
thesis like this with so many big time
mains a big center playmakers and um you
know definitely make your job easier but
just scared what we can do
he's Aaron Donald the Rams defense or
defensive tackle got the Chargers coming
up how big is this game I know it every
game is big but this is the battle for
bragging rights here in Los Angeles
yeah well we know we want to do we know
what we're trying to accomplish
um week to week you gotta go with the
man said that is a big game no good
anytime you know you can move in this
league and it's really hard to one win
in this league so you know we know we
got to do we know we gotta execute come
game time I get out there so we got a
good team coming what do you know about
Phillip Rivers can do it all no no
watching him so I know he tries to get
to them I know put some pressure on them
cuz you know like I said he's a great
quarterback and now you let a great
quarterback get time back I feel
comfortable there it'd be a long day for
us gotta get after him who was your team
growing up
why is it that Pittsburgh has a lot of
these players who come out of the
University but the team isn't any good
Aaron you know that you know that Pitt
football is not that good but you have
some great players you've come out of
there we ever hiccups here in here but
we'll get going
Phillip Rivers told me to say that just
to try to rile you up though just
[Laughter]
I'll leave you with this who takes more
pride in what their hair looks like
Jared golf or a coach McVeigh good to
visit with you hopefully we'll cross
paths in a friendly way though but good
luck against the Chargers Aaron and good
to visit with you again thank you as
Aaron Donald
he went to Pittsburgh they have a good
football team there for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]